wie geht es dir guten morgen ich hoffe
du fühlst dich gut wie geht es dir
guten morgen ich hoffe du fühlst dich
gut willkommen auf unserem kanal
willkommen auf unserem kanal
heute zeige ich dir ein neues video
heute lernen wir fragen auf deutsch und
wie man sich stellt heute lernen wir
fragen auf deutsch und wie man sich
stellt fangen wir also an
fangen wir also an im deutschen gibt es
sogenannte w fragen im deutschen gibt es
sogenannte w fragen
es sind fragen die mit dem buchstaben w
beginnen und detaillierte antwort fragen
sind
es sind fragen die mit dem buchstaben w
beginnen und detaillierte antwort fragen
sind w fragen sind offene fragen die man
nicht mit ja oder nein beantworten kann
w fragen sind offene fragen die man
sie werden auch ergänzungsfragen genannt
am anfang einer w frage steht ein frage
wort das meist mit dem buchstaben w
beginnt
sie werden auch ergänzungsfragen genannt
am anfang einer w frage steht ein frage
wort das meist mit dem buchstaben w
beginnt das hier sind einige der fragen
oder besser gesagt die am häufigsten
verwendeten
wer
wo
warum
wie
woher
wohin
welche welches welcher welchen welchem
wann
das hier sind einige der fragen oder
besser gesagt die am häufigsten
verwendeten
wer
wo
warum
wie
woher
wohin
welche welches welcher welchen welchem
wann
schauen wir uns die struktur für diese
fragen an
es ist sehr einfach schauen wir uns die
struktur für diese fragen an
es ist sehr einfach man stellt eine
frage wenn man seinen gesprächspartner
nach einem unbekannten sachverhalt fragt
diese frage kann man nicht mit ja oder
nein beantworten
man stellt eine w frage wenn man seinen
gesprächspartner nach einem unbekannten
sachverhalt fragt diese frage kann man
nicht mit ja oder nein beantworten
an erster stelle von w fragen steht ein
frage wort das meist mit dem buchstaben
w beginnt zum beispiel woher
so wie an erster stelle von w fragen
steht ein frage wort das meist mit dem
buchstaben w beginnt zum beispiel woher
[Musik]
wie nun die struktur dieser fälle ist
wie folgt
die frage plus konjugiert das verb plus
subjekt plus ergänzung nun die struktur
dieser fälle ist wie folgt
die frage plus konjugiert das verb plus
subjekt plus ergänzung es ist sehr
einfach
sehen wir es uns anhand der folgenden
beispiele an
es ist sehr einfach sehen wir es uns
anhand der folgenden beispiele an
wir beginnen mit wem wir beginnen mit
wer
wer hat das mittagessen gemacht wer hat
das mittagessen gemacht das habe ich
gemacht schmeckt es die das habe ich
gemacht schmeckt ist die ja es ist sehr
gut
ja es ist sehr gut wer kommt uns morgen
besuchen
wer kommt uns morgen besuchen mein vater
er möchte uns besuchen und mit uns zeit
verbringen
mein vater er möchte uns besuchen und
mit uns zeit verbringen
wer ist der autor des buches dass du
gerade liest
der autor ist der alltag in das buch
heißt 'herr der ringe' der autor ist der
alltag in das buch heißt 'herr der
ringe' es ist sehr gut du sagtest ist
lesen
es ist sehr gut du solltest es lesen
wer hat meinen kuchen gegessen
wer hat meinen kuchen gegessen andrea
hat ihn gegessen gestern kam sie mich
besuchen und ich habe es ihr angeboten
andrea hat ihn gegessen gestern kam sie
mich besuchen und ich habe es ihr
angeboten
du hast mir ja gesagt dass du ihn nicht
essen willst du hast mir ja gesagt dass
du ihn nicht essen willst
kommen wir nun zu wo kommen wir nun
sowohl
wo ist mein koffer
wo ist mein koffer dein körper steht auf
dem tisch
dein körper steht auf dem tisch
wo ist das haus seiner schwester wo ist
das haus seiner schwester das haus
meiner schwester ist in den bergen das
haus meiner schwester ist in den bergen
wo bist du
auf dem weg zum haus meines bruders auf
dem weg zum haus meines bruders
wo ist deine großmutter wo ist deine
großmutter meine großmutter ist bei
meiner schwester
sie hat dort letzten acht übernachtet
meine großmutter ist bei meiner
schwester sie hat dort letzten acht
übernachtet
jetzt kommen die was fragen jetzt kommen
die was fragen
was machst du da was machst du da ich
repariere das auto ich repariere das
auto
was wirst du sehen was wirst du sehen
einen thriller
ich liebe spannende filme einen thriller
ich liebe spannende filme was wünscht du
dir zum geburtstag
was wünscht du dir zum geburtstag ich
wünsche mir eine jeans und ein t shirt
ich wünsche mir eine jeans und ein t
shirt
warum es ist eine weitere der w-fragen
fahren wir mit den beispielen fort
warum haben sich chris und eva
gestritten
gestritten weil chris mit einer anderen
frau ausging und eva ist bemerkte weil
chris mit einer anderen frau ausging und
eva es bemerkte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
warum hast du mich gestern nicht
zurückgerufen
zurückgerufen weil ich den ganzen
nachmittag im büro war und tausend dinge
zu tun hatte
weil ich den ganzen nachmittag im büro
war und tausend dinge zu tun hatte
ich habe es vergessen es tut mir leid
warum hat sein unternehmen die
jahresabschlussveranstaltung abgesagt
warum hat ein unternehmen die
weil die verkäufe in diesem jahr nicht
sehr gut waren und das unternehmen kein
geld hat um die party zu organisieren
weil die verkäufe in diesem jahr nicht
sehr gut waren und das unternehmen kein
geld hat um die party zu organisieren
warum bist du so früh aufgestanden
warum bist du so früh aufgestanden weil
ich das auto zum mechaniker bringen
musste um es überprüfen zu lassen
es macht ein seltsames geräusch
weil ich das auto zum mechaniker bringen
musste um es überprüfen zu lassen
es macht ein seltsames geräusch
die frage nach dem wie ist eine weitere
die bei der informationsbeschaffung sehr
häufig gestellt wird sehen wir sie uns
an
die frage nach dem wie ist eine weitere
die bei der informationsbeschaffung sehr
häufig gestellt wird sehen wir sie uns
an
wie ist dein name wie ist dein name mein
name ist katar
mein name ist katar wie kontrolliert du
dein gewicht
wie kontrolliert du dein gewicht
ich esse gesund treibe sport und trinke
viel wasser ich esse gesund treibe sport
und trinke viel wasser wie hast du
herausgefunden dass dieses motorrad zum
verkauf steht wie hast du herausgefunden
dass dieses motorrad zum verkauf steht
ich habe mir die anzeige im internet
angesehen und sie hat mir gefallen
wie ist das wifi passwort ich muss mich
mit dem netzwerk verbinden
das passwort ist 02 78 94
jetzt kommen die fragen mit wo und woher
wo hast du diese neuen schuhe her wo
hast du diese neuen schuhe her
ich habe sie im einkaufszentrum gekauft
woher kommt dein vater
er kommt aus zürich
woher hast du diese köstlichen früchte
ich habe sie im supermarkt hier in der
nähe gekauft
die struktur die wir in den vergangenen
beispielen verwendet haben kann für
folgende w-fragen benutzt werden
wohin
welche
wann
die struktur die wir in den vergangenen
beispielen verwendet haben kann für
folgende w-fragen benutzt werden
wohin
welche
wann
die frage plus konjugierte sver plus
subjekt plus ergänzung
b frage plus konjugierte sver plus
du hast jetzt gelernt wie die w-fragen
funktionieren
jetzt möchte ich dir die ja nein fragen
zeigen
du hast jetzt gelernt wie die w-fragen
funktionieren
jetzt möchte ich dir die ja nein fragen
zeigen
diese fragen sind geschlossene fragen
und ihre antworten lauten ja oder nein
bist du müde ja oder nein
bist du müde bist du müde ja
ja
bist du verheiratet bist du verheiratet
ja oder nein
der aufbau ist wie folgt konjugierte
sver plus subjekt plus ergänzung
der aufbau ist wie folgt konjugiert es
wert plus subjekt plus ergänzung
sehen wir uns einige beispiele an
ledig bist du ledig
ja ja
hast du einen hund hast du einen hund
nein nein du kannst mit ja oder nein
antworten aber auch mit einer ergänzung
du kannst mit ja oder nein antworten
aber auch mit einer ergänzung
hast du einen hund
hast du einen hund nein ich habe keinen
hund ich habe eine katze
nein ich habe keinen hund ich habe eine
katze
hast du einen job hast du einen job
ja ich arbeite als pflegerin im
krankenhaus ja ich arbeite als pflegerin
im krankenhaus
ok ich hoffe dass sie mit diesen
beispielen lernen werdet fragen zu
stellen und ich hoffe dass ihr weiterhin
sehr fleißig mit uns lernen werdet
ok ich hoffe dass sie mit diesen
beispielen lernen werdet fragen zu
stellen und ich hoffe dass ihr weiterhin
sehr fleißig mit uns lernen werdet jetzt
kannst du diese fragen in den
kommentaren beantworten
jetzt kannst du diese fragen in den
welche sprache sprichst du
welche sprachen sprichst du bist du
ledig oder verheiratet
bist du ledig oder verheiratet
warum möchtest du deutsch lernen
gefällt dir dieses video er fällt hier
dieses video
vergesst nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren und gebt uns für dieses video
ein leib
beim best nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren und gebt uns für dieses video
ein leib
danke
tschüss